mamie de grâce ne
mon pas sous la gorge
àupidon
sa propre
flèche tant d'amoureux l'ont
essayé qui de leur bonheur ont payé ce
sarilège j'ai l'honneur de ne pas te
demander ta main ne gravons pas ns ns au
Badun
parchemin laissons le champ libre à
l'oiseau nous serons tous les de
prisonniers sur
parolele au diabl les maîtresses que qui
attachent les cœurs au que des
[Musique]
cassero j'ai l'honneur de ne pas te
demander ta main ne grabons pas ns au
bas d'un
[Musique]
parchemin Vénus se fait vieille souvent
elle perd son latin devant
là lesche
frit à aucun prix moi je je veux
effeuiller dans le pote au feu
la
marguerite j'ai l'honneur de ne pas te
demander ta main ne gravons pasons au
bas d'un
parchemin on leur ôte bien des
attraits en dévoilant trop les secrets
de ml
ine l'encre des billets doux Palit vite
entre les feuillet des
livreux de
cuisine j'ai l'honneur de ne pas te
demander ta main ne gravons pas nos noms
au bas d'un
parchemin il peut sembler de tout repos
de mettre à long ombre fond d'un poau
de
confiture la jolie pomme défendue mais
elle est cuite elle a perdu son goût
nature j'ai l'honneur de ne pas te
demander ta main ne gravons pas nos noms
au bas d'un
parchemin de servante n'ai pas besoin et
du ménage et de ses soins je te
[Musique]
dispense qu'un éternel
fiancé à la dame de mes pensées
toujours je
pense j'ai l'honneur de ne pas te
[Musique]
demander ta main ne gravons pas n n auas
d'un
[Musique]
parchemin